good morning Jason how are you good
morning dad don't well how are you I'm
doing okay I'm curious first game as a
broadcaster first game as a player more
nervous with which one oh that's a tough
one I think it's hard for me to remember
back that many years ago but you know
anytime you're a rookie playing for Bill
Parcells as he makes his debut
you know the nerves were amped up you
had that feeling in the stomach so I
would probably say as a rookie player
coming to Dallas as it tied in and as
bill referred to me a lot you know I was
lost I was I was a ball in high grass
and in a lot of ways but you know it's
funny when you go into broadcasting and
great opportunity to call my first game
but it's similar I mean I just really
reminded myself to smell the roses you
know to the great history of Monday
Night Football and be able to carry on
that vision and look that chairs also
awfully big you know and the job that
those guys have done that before me so I
said I was standing most of the game
that's a big seat to feel and but I had
a lot of fun and honestly then it's much
like when you play you know you just
continue to work at it find ways to
improve have a lot of fun certainly a
lot of areas to clean up but I'm really
enjoying an opportunity to stay around
the game and share some of my insight
and my knowledge over 15 years of
playing it and so having a lot of fun
good team around me how much did Tony
Romo's success play into you taking this
John well I think more than anything
else I caught myself watching him last
year let's play the first time I really
paid attention to a broadcast crew on
that level you know and what all goes
into it and the success that he had and
you know attention when you when you
dive into it and certainly I studied a
lot of guys and a lot of different
sports you know it's really hard to
define what it is what are those traits
but you know it when you hear it yeah
much like yourself you know it's like
it's a good listen and and you
appreciate when you you see it and
there's tips and pointers that you can
learn from different guys on how you
explain it and
not to go to too much football and on a
level that everybody can comprehend and
appreciate and makes it enjoyable and
entertaining and fun and so but you got
to stay true to yourself and that's what
I've tried to do and Tony set the bar
really high with his success and what he
and Jim were able to achieve together
last year finished his sentence if I
wasn't offered Monday Night Football oh
that's hard that's hard I was offered it
so I was able to say that I took Monday
Night Football I you know I don't know
it was really hard decision I would have
to say that you know I was fortunate
enough to still have the opportunity
with Jerry to be able to play but like
anything you know I said it when I
retired you know rather three hours too
early than a minute too late and this
opportunity to stay around the game on
on this stage and to carry on the
tradition of Monday Night Football man
are you kidding me I mean it doesn't get
much better than that and so that's what
I'm excited about and look I understand
it you know it gets hot in the kitchen
the expectations certainly they were
high as a player for the Dallas Cowboys
but you know it's broadcasting I mean
everybody has pointers and what you can
do better and you know it's it's your
first game and so I think more than
anything else I hope to develop and a
lot of ways of a voice of reason and
showcasing what I see and how quickly I
can share that and you know it's
enjoyable people sitting around the
house on the couch on Monday night after
spending the last three or four days
watching ball they want to enjoy that
and so I thought we got off to a good
start and plenty to improve could you
play today I don't know that anybody
would say that they can't play any
competitor would say you know it's funny
when I retired I was going through that
process I visited with coach Parcells
who was great mentor of mine my first
four years and my coach here in Dallas
and he said Jason you're gonna feel like
you're 45 years old you can still go run
up there and win on that why option and
heck man you probably can
you know you probably be able to do it
and so yeah I think you always feel that
way but father time waits on nobody you
know and
and you see it with players it's a tough
League and so yeah if it was a third and
sixth I feel like I go out there and
help a team yeah I mean I think we would
all say that but there's a lot more that
goes into it than just that I want you
to be an analyst now and look at yeah
the Downloads Cowboys what do you see
well that wasn't the way they wanted to
start the game of the season off last
year I mean last week when we watched
that game you know I think to provide a
little perspective you can't get ahead
of yourself it's one game but they did
not play well I thought the defense
showed some really good signs of what
they can develop into with the pressure
they're getting on the quarterback the
young corners and deep into backs being
able to really play well and embrace
that stage of what's expected on that
defense and coming into its own
offensively I think like you know most
quarterbacks in the league you need
those pieces around you and so they'll
find ways to get Zeke Elliott going I
mean you're going to see a lot of those
eight-man boxes
I think the concern or what you weren't
able to see and play affected on was
being able to stretch the field and move
the ball and you I think dak has all
those intangibles and we'll find it and
evaluate it you know not having Travis
rhetoric in there I think really affects
them not only didn't all-pro center but
the communication and how he handles all
that and so you know that wasn't the way
they wanted to start tough loss they've
got to get that off into going but I
think Linehan and Garrett and dak they
they have the pieces in place that they
can they just need to find ways to get
those explosives and and those big
chunks and that's yeah everybody wants
to do that right Danny that's you know
every offense is saying they need to do
that but they're doing it a little bit
unconditional ways you know because you
want to run the football so much well
then you know you got to have some of
those play actions and some of those
pieces that come in behind it and they
weren't able to consistently get those
big strikes when you think back to 2016
that was a big difference they were able
to kind of we I guess in 2016 you're
able to find a lot of those plays much
like Russell Wilson you know when you
think when they had their big success it
it all works together the defense
getting turnover stops saw Dallas
defense taking big strides now that
getting
all offensively they want to run that
football but you saw it in that game and
there was a lot of those dirty looks
where so many guys that are down in the
box and given that attention to Eliot
yeah and I think that's what's gonna
happen but you know I'd look at dak
Prescott and I just don't think he has
that bailout receiver where you and des
could provide that and he doesn't have
that he's got smaller guys they're
they're still working on a tight end and
if I'm a defense I just look at what
Carolina did not that you can be
Carolina's defense but I just take that
blueprint I'm gonna say eight guys in
the box I'm gonna dare you to beat us
we'll have man coverage let me see what
you can do duck yeah I think that that's
what you're gonna see you're gonna
continue to see it and they're aware of
that and I think you're gonna see more
of the run past options finding those
ways and early downs you know I I'm
studying the Chicago game that's who we
call next week and you see Matt and
Aggie do a lot of that for the
quarterback and it's just high
percentage throwing catch that they stay
ahead of the chains and you know I think
back going back to that formula of
winning on first down and second down
what's it's not as easy just handing it
off all the time I mean sometimes you
got to use that in the passing game so
that's that's fair to say I think
they're well aware that they're gonna
have those types of looks those dirty
eight-man front and finding ways to get
those chunks on the outside haven't you
know Beasley showed that he can do a lot
of different things but yeah I mean
you're gonna have to have those
explosive plays and that's I'm sure
they're studying that right now to say
hey that's that that's where our
attention we need to be better at good
luck with Miller light more importantly
Monday Night Football and you can see
and hear Jason Witten it'll be the
Seahawks Bears at 8:15 Eastern coming up
on Monday night
Jason good to catch up with you again
thanks for joining us all right thanks
wrap me on Dan that's Jason Witten
former Cowboys tied in if you don't get
the Monday night job now maybe he would
have gotten another analyst role at
another network but that Monday night
job and if he would have asked me I
would have told him take the job if they
offer you Monday night take it because
if you're good enough you can hold on to
that for ten years but that's one of
those unique situations and that would
be one that I would walk away
from football a year early than a year
late with something like that for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience channel
239 on Direct TV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]